netflix enríquez usted ha recibido un
premio recientemente por un trabajo que
presentó en el marco de sus cursos de
lengua en la universidad puede
explicarnos de que se trató ese trabajo
yo escribí un papel abro por las lenguas
indígenas y qué significa para mí
entonces era algo personal
mi papel porque yo soy salvadoreña y yo
soy también indígena
y ese lenguaje y quiero aprenderlo y yo
quiero compartirlo con la comunidad para
que es más fácil
a aprenderlo
cuando hablamos de la lengua indígena
que usted quiere aprender cuál es esta
lengua
ese es tener su cine es de las personas
tener
y quienes hablan o qué cantidad de gente
habla esta lengua al donde se encuentra
la gente que la habla
cesc actúan alberto aneto para word
western cordis y también un poco te
elige con yo pienso
y cómo
un poquito más de 10.000 personas hablan
este lenguaje
y parte de su trabajo si no me equivoco
se refiere a la relación que existe
entre la lengua entre los idiomas y el
bienestar de las personas si pueden
ampliar nos un poco la idea cuál es esa
relación
el lenguaje es algo que usamos para
comunicarnos comunicarnos con otras
personas entonces es bien importante el
lenguaje que usamos en la vida
y si no conocemos es el lenguaje de
nosotros
no sé qué tiempo se nos viene
solos y como no
no hay conexión con nosotros por qué
si nos si no yo no sé el tener su dinero
yo no tengo mucha conexión a la cultura
porque la cultura está bien conectada
con el lenguaje
y cuál es su conexión con esta lengua su
madre es de origen indígena en cierto sí
pero también habla español porque sus
padres de origen salvadoreño sí y que
significó para ustedes esto de crecer
con en el contexto de dos culturas
distintas que se juntan en su persona
que ha sido para usted esto
personalmente
era algo
que no sabía mucho porque yo nunca he
estado en el salvador
solo crecí aquí en saskatoon
bastante de personas vieron que yo no
soy realmente salvadoreña dios no soy
realmente tener
esto era algo difícil a comprender
porque estas personas estaban diciendo
esto porque si no soy salvadoreña si no
soy tener queso entonces
y cómo se define a usted misma entonces
ahora estoy confortable de decir que yo
soy salvadoreña y que yo soy de ley tal
vez no crecí en el país o tal vez no
crecí hablando el idioma pero
ahora si estoy tratando de conectarme
con esas cosas así
realmente si no soy estas dos cosas que
soy
noches
mezcle una de sus preocupaciones o de
sus intereses mejor dicho es el de crear
un programa de revitalización de la
lengua
si a qué se refiere con este término de
revitalización
en las últimas en los últimos años
bastante de las personas que hablan que
son
más mayor de edad
bastante las personas más jóvenes no
hablan el idioma porque hay el inglés
pero es bien importante yo pienso
preservar ese lenguaje
yo quiero preservar eso yo quiero que
hay más personas que hablen ese idioma
y para generar un programa de
revitalización hace falta un interés
masivo por parte de la gente en
participar cree que esa iniciativa
contaría con el público suficiente como
para darle nuevo aire a esta lengua
indígena
que yo vi hay bastante de interés a
aprender el lenguaje pero no hay
suficiente programas no hay suficiente
y cosas para emprender aprender entonces
yo quiero creer más
hagan cosas para que es más accesible
aprender lengua el lenguaje
y cómo fue en su caso la experiencia de
aprender español en saskatchewan hay
suficiente gente para practicar en
español allí en su provincia sí con mi
familia
cuando estaba más chiquitas sólo hablaba
el español con mi familia pero ahora
pienso que hay más retiros en sus casas
y yo puedo hablar el español con ellos
también para el caso específico de su
padre que es de origen salvadoreño la
integración de la sociedad de
saskatchewan fue fácil ya que él no
hablaba la lengua nativa y por lo que
entiendo tampoco hablaba inglés o no
hablaba mucho al menos cuando llegó
en ese entonces era difícil para él
porque tenía que ir al school otra vez y
bastante de personas no comprendió que
no podría hablar inglés y lo trataban
mal entonces
en la reciente semana de logros
indígenas en la que usted recibió el
premio recientemente el lema principal
fue traducido al español caminar juntos
qué significa para usted esta idea de
caminar juntos
yo pienso que las personas en la vida
a un momento están ayudando a alguien o
no necesitan ayuda entonces yo pienso
que estamos juntos ayudando a nosotros
eso
eso es qué significa ese tema para mí
porque no quiero que nadie se sienta que
no tienen alguien para compartir esos
problemas con ellos
usted está estudiando en la universidad
de saskatchewan una carrera que es lo
que está relacionado al menos con la
lingüística
y cuál es su proyecto a futuro
yo quiero crear este programa pero
quiero tomar el maestro él es primero
quiero aprender más el lenguaje para qué
yo puedo compartir con otras personas
más fácil viene su experiencia personal
así en saskatchewan y si conoce en
canadá en general cree que existen
suficientes alternativas suficientes
recursos suficiente apoyo para la
preservación de la lengua por un lado y
la cultura general indígena aquí en el
país
no pienso en los últimos años
si ese interés es más fuerte ahora
pero
yo pienso que todavía necesitamos más
ayuda con eso
estos programas necesitan dinero
necesitan
compañías que quieren publicar los
libros y ross
materiales para los pares los lenguajes
entonces los decía necesitamos estudiar
un poco más para
que es el más joven
como usted dijo hace unos instantes
conocer una lengua es conocer una
cultura usted conoce y habla de español
le interesaría en algún momento conocer
la cultura salvadoreña y vivirla en su
lugar de origen que es el salvador
yo quiero conocer más la cultura pero
también mi familia vivió en la guerra el
salvador
para ellos para regresar al salvador
para vivir para visitar
yo pienso estar estar bien pero no sé si
puedo vivir allí porque ya tengo mi vida
aquí
pero si quiero conocer más el salvador
por último mes link fue importante para
usted recibir este premio
era una sorpresa para mí yo no pensé que
iba a pasar
estoy contenta que el bien feliz que
desvíe este premio
quiero trabajar más duro para que este
programa puede realizarse
leslie enríquez muchas gracias por esta
entrevista con radio canadá
internacional y muchas gracias